[Applaudissements]
voici la municipalité où tous les rêves
étaient permis au début des années 60
[Musique]
la ville de Gagnon sur la côte nord a
attiré de nombreuses jeunes familles et
des travailleurs séduits par un grand
projet économique minier
maison Arena église école furent
construit à toute vitesse pour
accueillir rapidement le bassin de 4000
nouveaux habitants
la ville rurale de bécancourt au centre
du Québec pour y vivre aujourd'hui le
même genre des sorts elle a l'âge j'ai
pas de boule de cristal vraiment pas
mais on est très ambitieux pour le
projet qui arrive chez nous c'est
certain lancé par le fleuve sur une
grande partie pour la mairie de
bécancourt c'est l'équivalent du
silicone vallée de la batterie
automobile qui s'en vient chez elle le
gouvernement choisi son parc industriel
comme berceau de la filière la plaque
tournante pour l'alimentation des
véhicules électriques mais les
fabricants de batterie qui construisent
leur usine ici son principe
ils veulent produire dès 2025 ce qui
laisse à peine deux ans pour
littéralement transformer bécancourt
de travail oui c'est ça en partant de ça
mais là on a pu vraiment définir
notre vision menace qui guide votre
projet c'est ça les opportunités parmi
les opportunités Lucie alors estime que
le projet va attirer 5000 travailleurs
dans sa ville est-ce que c'est
l'estimation que vous avez vous aussi
globale moi je pense qu'on peut espérer
avoir plus de votre vie dans l'industrie
éventuellement
au cours d'une visite guidée du site
avec le ministre Pierrefitte Gabin on
constate une véritable course contre la
montre au sud de l'autoroute 30
des voies desserte un réseau d'acqueduc
des égouts et même un chemin de fer sont
en construction tout pour satisfaire les
multinationales l'usine de JM Bosco par
exemple cet embrasse sur un terrain de 5
km
pour moi pour mes équipes ce dossier qui
est un gros challenge et le challenge
vient vraiment des échéanciers qui sont
très courts et puis c'est la rapidité à
laquelle il faut l'exécuter le PDG du
site reconnaît que beaucoup de projets
annoncés ici dans le passé n'ont jamais
vu le jour devant nous les vestiges de
l'ancienne centrale Gentilly s'impose
dans le paysage
les Mauriciens et les centres équats ont
mangé leur pain noir trop souvent au
chômage rappelle le député de Nicolet
bécancourt
s dernière année ça a été difficile ici
avec la fermeture de grande entreprise
je fais souvent des comparaisons avec ce
que les portes et papier ont été pour la
Mauricie je pense la batterie peut
remplacer ça
encore faut-il réaliser le tour de force
trouver les 10 000 travailleurs requis
d'ici deux ans plusieurs spécialisés
dans la fabrication de batterie pour
véhicules électriques et tout ça en
pleine pénurie de main d'oeuvre je pense
qu'on va avoir beaucoup d'étrangers
temporaires qui vont venir ici là-bas
est ouverte on peut un peu amener autant
de monde qu'on veut pour combler des
postes qui peuvent combler ici au Québec
il va falloir faire du recrutement à
l'extérieur est-ce que on va aller dans
les maritimes où ce que ça parle un
petit peu plus français est-ce que on va
avoir une stratégie au niveau de
l'immigration je sais pas avec cette
afflu anticipé la ville ne comptera plus
seulement 14000 habitants moi je pense
qu'on pourra aller à 20000 assez
facilement il y a un projet de
développement qui a peut-être un
potentiel de pas loin de 5000 nouvelles
résidences mais à ces nouvelles maisons
devront aussi se greffer des services
même pas d'école secondaire on aura
vraiment besoin du gouvernement du
Québec pour accélérer les choses ici
donc une nouvelle école primaire qui est
déjà dans les cartons un nouveau CPE
également 10 000 employés c'est beaucoup
de gens ressources humaines en santé
sécurité c'est beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent en logistique et dans
d'autres domaines
l'Université du Québec à Trois-Rivières
ça sert à créer des programmes
et d'oeuvre les chercheurs
universitaires travailleront aussi avec
les entreprises pour développer
l'expertise du Québec en matière de
transition énergétique ce qu'on appelle
une zone d'innovation sera ainsi formée
avec les villes de bécancourt
Trois-Rivières et Shawinigan on manque
d'espace ce projet-là il ne se fera pas
sans que notre université puisse croître
pour justement rencontrer les besoins il
n'y a pas que l'université qui doit
s'agrandir le port de bécancourt aussi
pour accueillir plus de cargo on
pourrait facilement ici penser à
bécancourt on aurait dix milliards
d'investissements
gagnant au Québec une ville fantôme
d'ici le mois de juin 1985 de 1960 à 85
toute la ville Nord côtière de Gagnon
battait aussi au rythme d'un méga projet
qui n'aura connu du succès pendant
seulement 20 ans quand j'ai en mini a
décidé de partir toute la région s'était
fondée
aujourd'hui la ville de Gagnon n'existe
plus complètement rayé de la carte du
Québec
mais ce n'est pas ce qui attend
beckencourt sera sur le gouvernement
contrairement à Gagnon situé dans un
secteur isolé bécancourt se retrouve au
centre du Québec au cœur de l'activité
économique pour la région les retombées
sont estimés à un milliard et demi de
dollars d'ici 10 ans le nouveau clone
dike c'est ici espère-t-on ici Véronique
prince Radio-Canada Québec